Ronny if you want to believe him Ronny
the limo driver at one point Ronny said
that he's leaving at the end of this
contract either way is that right I
didn't realize that was where we were
with Ronny Ronny 69 he'll be 71 yeah but
he's got more energy the guy still [ __ ]
like a young man I mean maybe he stopped
doing that he could work a little longer
yep I'm interviewing new security people
no short people - heck yeah I mean
canoeing somebody who is about 4 foot 11
in a 74 years old
Ronnie was guarding me the other day we
were walking I go this guy can barely
walk how is he guarding are you still
sticking by that Ronnie like I deserve
some notice I mean I am starting indeed
I told your dad is that it I mean I felt
like it was sort of vague still I wanted
to finish that official is it official
that you are done at the end of my
contract as far as I know yes what do
you mean as far as you know who else
would know no I say as far as they know
him that's those you don't want my plan
that my plan is to replace you at the
end of that time yes Wow Wow is right
why no I just can't believe it is it
there a time that you just want to lay
back and well what do you have back pain
pain pain what the [ __ ] is your problem
over there is this season you're going
to sleep also
hey job what you want to do with your
life I mean you you get a lot of fun out
of this show no I enjoy I love it here
you know quitter and then you get on the
air and you bow though off and
everything you know I know I know he's
gonna be miserable why do you think I'll
be miserable because if we're still here
and you're not you're gonna hate it
but I won't be here I'm gonna move away
where are you going I'm planning to move
to Vegas if you leave who's gonna
protect us from the poison bagels don't
what Gary's doughnuts yeah it's time to
hang up the [ __ ] rings oh yeah at some
point your [ __ ] is gonna start not
working all that great it probably won't
yeah I'm assuming you're probably just
gonna have to go down on Stephanie every
night I think that what he's doing is
he's conserving himself for that no why
is he why do you
thanks Ronnie he'll turn into a lesbian
cuz it'll be able to do I think that
because you've burning the candle at
both ends here no putting the candle in
my ass yes al you're on the air in
Massachusetts [ __ ] tree why am I in
my tree
dude I don't cut my left nut off the
driver guy likes Howard around dude I've
been here 34 years okay here's where are
you going dude
I'm going nowhere dude the whole plan to
go nowhere oh you go [ __ ] drive in
Massachusetts and you're complaining I'm
not complaining is Stefanie looking
forward to seeing you all day now should
be at work she'll be working what are
you gonna do I'll be spending time with
my dildos you don't read you don't have
any hobbies you know what he's gonna do
Howard yeah he's gonna get his car and
drive around I know he might as well
drive me let's see what can I do today I
know I'll Drive to Henderson is back
yeah Fred what are you gonna do if I
retire I'm gonna go in and subway with
my Ronnie puppet right